so um this will be a fun class today we
are doing the Great
Pyramid okay so um the Great Pyramid was
built about
2500 BC that's 4,500 Years Ago by a
pharaoh named uh
curfew and um it was one of the
seven uh great wonders of the um ancient
world it's the only one that's still
standing um from
2500 until 14400 uh CE which is about
4,000 years it was the
tallest man man-made building in the
world okay um the Great Pyramid um the
direction is too North meaning you can
actually use the pyramids as a compass
to tell the directions
um let's look at the um architecture of
the Great Pyramid so the center is
something called The King's chamber
that's where the king's mummy rests in
the
sarcophagus um there's a grand gallery
that gives you access to the king's
chamber and then a slope and then it's a
pyramid structure and on the top of the
pyramid is what is called a Ben bed or
the
uh the P the Pion okay the P the Pyon
okay and it is extremely significant
culturally and religiously in Egypt
because in Egyptian mythology the
religion um the Creator God atum he's
known as atum he's also known as Rah the
son
God first came into existence on the Ben
Ben so imagine a large dark ocean
there's nothing and then suddenly
emerges a mound okay called a benden and
that's where comes the CR God atum or
raah okay that's one Legend the other
Legend is from the dark ocean of space
comes down a Ben
band and on top of it rests atum okay so
this idea of the pordan the Ben Ben it
is
Central to the idea of Creation in Egan
mythology so this is an
extremely
powerful and beautiful Monument to EG
Egyptian culture architecturally
Napoleon who visited the Great Pyramid
he he calculated that if you took all
the stones from the Great Pyramid you
could actually build a wall around the
perimeter of
France there's more material in the
Great Pyramid except for two structures
the first structure is the Great Wall of
China there's more Stone in the great in
the Great Wall of China okay there's
more Stone there's more material in um
three gorgeous Dam also in
China okay and it took them about 26
years to build this
pyramid so today in today's class I'm
going to look at three questions the
first question is how do they build this
because it's still with us today you
actually go to Egypt and visit the Great
Pyramid second question is why did they
build this what was the purpose and the
third question
is why did they stop bu in the
pyramids okay so those those are the
three questions we're looking at we're
looking at today how was it built why
was it built and why did the Egyptians
stop building uh the pyramids so um um
how it was built is an extremely
controversial question that has plagued
historians and otologists and
archaeologist for hundreds of years okay
um and originally a Greek historian but
Herodotus proposed the idea the pyramid
was built in steps okay so it was first
a step pyramid and then using Poli they
pull the stones up okay and it's it was
it was the accepted idea for for the
longest time because there's no better
idea but architecturally that has been
uh disproven okay it can't work that
way um then about 10 years ago there was
a French architect named John Pierre
houdin okay H oou the houdin and he's an
architect he's never been in Egypt
doesn't speak Arabic never studi Egypt
but his father and him were very
interested in how the good parent was
constructed so he came up with this
Theory and they run they've run computer
stimulations and discovered this to be
true there's also a lot of physical
evidence to suggest this theory is true
okay so so this is how they built the
Great Pyramid what they did was they
first constructed a external ramp in
order to build a base okay so you now
have the
base and then from the base what they
did was um they built two structures
okay and this is what they call
counterweight counter weights okay so
these counterweights are like polies
which allows them pull the stones up uh
to uh up high okay and then surrounding
these two
structures is what they call a Eternal
spiral lamp uh ramp okay to carry the
stones
up and so what they did was they
basically built the pyramids from the
inside
out and then once they built the
structure they covered it up with
Limestone so that it reflects in the in
the sun okay if you actually were living
back then and you saw the the pyramids
from a distance you would think it was
the star that has come down on the
planet
Earth okay so that's how they built um
the pyramid but then this raises another
interesting question is how they come up
with this plan and how were they able to
do this without Blueprints and without
um basically writing or modern
engineering techniques and the answer is
if you think about it um what they did
was they build a model right beside the
pyramid which allowed them to figure out
how to build the larger pyramid
okay um but it otologists still believe
this was not possible because they
believe that Egyptians didn't have the
intellectual capacity to imagine this to
be true okay and I'll show you later on
that they that they actually did that
we're we underestimate their
imagination um and their intellectual
capacity right so that answers the first
question pretty easily how is it built a
more controversial question is why was
it built and for the longest
time the accepted theory is this was a
tomb
okay a
tomb the reason why is Egyptians
believed in the afterlife and so the
theory is this pyramid is designed to
ease the pharaoh's transition into the
heavens where he would become a star or
a
sun and um so the common phrase is this
is almost a resurrection machine where
the Pharaoh goes up to the to the sky
and then after a few centuries he he re
reincarnates inside the
pyramid and the structure is meant to
accomplish this and again this is the
generally accepted Theory
today
but there are three major problems with
this
Theory which basically makes it uh which
basically discounts it okay the first
major problem is there are about 100
pyramids in Egypt okay 100 or more we
don't know
okay we have not found a mummy or a body
inside any sagus inside the
pyramids so this is a problem if this is
a tomb why is there no there no body we
can't find the body okay so that's one
problem second problem is
this um for this a tomb this
implies that the Pharaoh when because
the Pharaohs are divine right they are
um basically the emation of God on Earth
this means that when they come to the
planet Earth and they become the Pharaoh
their priority is to build their own
tomb right does that make any sense they
come to Earth and they're like okay well
I'm gonna die so I want I want to get
out of here as soon as possible so let's
build that
tomb right now the problem is is that
this would imply that the Pharaoh sees
the Egyptian people as his slaves right
you exist in order for me to
live and
so
um but the problem is that in it
mythology gods are considered
benefactors of the human race okay so
for example atum he is the one who gave
life to the world but then his son his
descendant oaris another God gave
civilization to Egypt and then Horus the
son of oares gave the institution of
kingship to Egypt okay so these Gods
come to Earth in order to um help the
human race develop in some capacity so
it doesn't making any sense that the
pharaoh's primary purpose when he's on
Earth is to create a tomb because that's
a very selfish
reason okay does that make sense and the
third problem with this is just pure
logic if you're a FOH and your primary
concern is the afterlife resurrecting
yourself and the pyramid is a primary
means of accomplishing this and it takes
about 26 years or 30 years to build a
pyramid how can you be sure that you
won't die before the pyramid is built
right that's a
problem okay so these are three logical
problems but again otologist insists
that it is a tomb okay primarily because
of the way that Egyptians understand the
afterlife okay so here's some evidence
to suggest it is a tomb this is um
considered um a writing of a pharaoh to
his son about what the pyramid
represents so this is what he says make
your grave well furnished and prepare
thy place in the west okay the West is
where they go off to
die look death counts little for us okay
we can conquer death look life is valued
highly by us we want to become
immortal The House of the Dead meaning
the tomb is for life okay so the pyramid
is what will make us Immortal all right
so this is um again how highly debated
today so logically speaking it doesn't
make sense that that the pyramids are a
tomb but there's allot of evidence to
suggest it is a tomb and because of this
debate different theories have been
proposed as to the purpose of the uh
pyramid and there are lots of really
strange theories out there okay lots of
really strange theories uh one really
interesting theory was proposed by a man
named Nicola Tesla uh the found the the
creator of electricity basically
and his idea was this he studied the
architecture of the pyramid and he
proposed the pyramid was a battery
system okay in order to
create
free sorry to create free clean
energy and the theory is this okay the
theory is first of all if you look at
the king's chamber
um the sound frequency in it is FP and
fshp is also the frequency of planet
Earth okay so it seems like the pyramid
is
attune to the planet
Earth second of
all if you look at um where the pyramids
are geographically it's two North okay
it's put in a place that matches um the
directions of the Earth Earth and so the
theory is the
direction of the pyramid is capturing
the energy from the electromagnetic
field that the Earth
generates okay and the third explanation
is
inside um the pyramid are Granite stones
and outside are limestones and this is
the perfect way to trap and store energy
okay so think of a solar panel uh where
the Sun and the Moon reflects light onto
the pyramids and the energy stored
inside the
pyramid
okay and so this is a great Theory and
again there are lots of people who
believe in this because um this is
actually much more plausible than the
tomb Theory but the problem with this of
course is it doesn't work scientifically
and also you have the question of if
they produce all this free clean energy
what are they using it
for
okay so this leads us with a big
question
why did they build the Great Pyramid and
today I want I want to propose to you
another solution okay the the solution
is this my belief is the Great Pyramid
was designed as Egypt's Manhattan
Project okay the man project as you know
uh was a World War II project in order
to build the nuclear bom bomb and you
can argue nuclear bomb is Humanity's
greatest invention ever it took about
130,000 people over five to six years
working in United States in Canada in UK
and these are the best scientists in the
world at this time okay working
collectively in order to create the
nuclear
bomb and you can also make the argument
that there are many working on the
project who believe the man project was
about bringing peace to Earth Eternal
peace it was ultimately about mastering
the secrets of the
universe channeling the power of God in
order to create Eternal peace to bring
God on Earth and You' also argue that
because we've had no major war after
World War II fingers
crossed they were right
okay so that's my argument to you the
Egyptians conceptualized and created the
Great Pyramid in order to harness the
power of God in order to create Eternal
peace on Earth to bring an end to
history to bring an end to pain
suffering and
death okay
so before I Pro provide the evidence let
me explain this theory in general okay
and again um this is my theory it's
speculation it's imagination but I think
it makes sense okay so so let me explain
the theory to
you the trick is the body of the
feral The Mummy okay now if the Pharaoh
was divine and Theus believed he was
divine then after his death the body
would be sacred in the vine right but
not only that but you think about it
after the Pharaoh dies he would Ascend
to the Heavens to become a star or a sun
right the body then we becomes a portal
or a mechanism for you to communicate
with the Pharaoh while he's in the
heavens you can also argue the body The
Mummy could be a mechanism for you to
channel the pharaoh's powers on Earth
okay so imagine this you have the
sarcophagus The Mummy is inside okay
okay and then you have the grand gallery
and inside the grand Gallery what are
people doing they are there praying and
worshiping the
feral which then draws the energy from
the star bars onto the
Earth and then because of the
Limestone this energy is
reflected across
Egypt so the
entire nation can bask in the Divine
energy of the Pharaoh okay so Nichol
Tessa said that this was a battery in
order to Channel free clean energy to
power Egypt
well what if we change this to Divine
energy
instead the pyramid was a battery to
channel Divine energy in order to power
Egypt
right now let me discuss if you are a
worshipper in the grand Gallery what are
you experiencing
okay well first of all you're
experiencing the Collision the Nexus of
life and death right because the Pharaoh
he's dead but he's still alive through
your
faith even though you're you're mortal
you're now communication with God okay
so this is a Nexus of life and
death this Grand Channel sorry this
Grand Gallery if you actually have a
chance to visit
it in um Egypt okay you re you'll
recognize that this
almost looks like a womb okay all right
so it's almost like you're inside a dark
space that's taking you back to the
point of your birth right but it's also
you can also be seen as a tomb a place
where you're being buried so this is
also like
another Collision conflation or Nexus
of being born and
dying if you were outside and you just
saw the pyramid again you would think of
it as a star that has landed on earth
right so this is a conflation a Nexus of
Heaven and
Earth it's a collision a Nexus
of myth and reality you can also make
the argument that through Divine worship
what you're really doing is you're
reversing the great bang sorry the Big
Bang You're reversing the Big Bang
you're bringing into this one space and
you are creating
Oneness
wholeness and
completeness you have achieved the Union
and the unity of all things through your
faith in the
Pharaoh which gives you divine energy to
be born a
new cleanse of your
sins and to cleanse others of their sins
to create a moral
Egypt
okay does that make sense all right so
that's a theory so now let me explain
the idea of Eternal
peace why would the
pyramid create the idea of Eternal peace
well the first reason
is even though Egypt was a Empire
Dynasty at this point it was still
divided culturally okay there were at
least four different cultures scattered
around Egypt and they all had their own
mythologies they had all their own
religious practices they had their own
faiths right so the point of this
pyramid was to unite all these faiths
into One Singular object in the worship
of the
Pharaoh if you were an Egyptian citizen
if you were in Egypt and you looked at
the pyramids you can not help but think
this is God on Earth okay this
centers your faith and it forces your
obedience and your submission to higher
authority which is a theough okay that's
the
first reason Unity second is the idea of
a so so let's just say you're a powerful
Army and you're an enemy and you want to
conquer Egypt well you send your Scouts
to Egypt and they see the pyramids right
the Great Pyramid what are they seeing
they're seeing God on Earth okay so
you're not going to attack God on Earth
you're going to run away so it creates a
sense of awe around the world right the
last
thing
is um the domination of
nature so
through divine inspiration Egyptians are
able to sum summon the Great Pyramid and
it shows the God's ability to control
nature why is this important because the
source of Egyptian wealth and power is
the Nile
River okay the Nile River and basically
it's the N River that's made Egypt the
wealthiest country in the world for
thousands of
years okay so the thing about the Nile
is if it's in a good mood you live a
very good life because the now just
floods uh um just floods a bangs and
leaves this rich soil and then you just
throw some seeds in it and then you can
grow all these crops very easily okay
very very it's very easy life and you
can become very wealthy that way so if
it's in good mood then you are a very
happy person
but if it's in a bad mood okay for
example it doesn't flood or it floods
too much you could die of Salvation or
of drowning okay so it's very important
for you a to for you to be able to
control the moods of the Gods and that's
what the pyramid is meant to
do the Egyptian word for uh Egypt is
KET which basically means Black Earth so
the source of all life in Egypt is the
soil right the back the Black Earth
that's okay so let's go back to this
quotation and now we can we can
actually understand it in a different
way right make your grave well furnished
and prepare thy place in the west that's
fine now look death counts little for us
we're Gods we're pharaohs we will never
die so we don't worry about death we
don't have to worry about dying okay
look life is valued highly by us what is
life life are humans the Egyptian people
our concern as pharaohs is for the
well-being of the Egyptian people so
that's our primary
responsibility okay The House of the
Dead the pyramid is for Life the pyramid
is our Legacy to The Egan people it is
our benevolence it is our generosity it
is how we will make egyp Eternal and
stable and
prosperous
okay so that's my theory of what the
pyramid is it is really the Manhattan
Project an attempt by the Pharaohs to
bring Eternal
peace okay any questions about this
about this idea be before I elaborate on
it and present the evidence for for it
any questions about
this you don't find you guys don't find
this
controversial what are you confused by
anything do you want to challenge me
before I present the
evidence okay all right so let let me
start presenting the evidence
okay so um the first piece of evidence
is again um Egyptian
mythology all right so in is mythology
and it's very different from other
mythologies we'll study in the future
like that of
Mesopotamia the gods give everything to
the people okay the people don't really
do anything Rah gives life asaurus gives
civilization Horus provides the
kingship Okay so so the Egyptian
understanding uh of the relationship
with the gods is basically if they
worship the gods good well enough the
gods will always reward
them okay so the idea that the the gods
will make the people build tombs doesn't
really make any sense okay it makes more
sense the Pharaoh is helping the
Egyptians a achieve Eternal Peace by
inspiring them to build a the
pyramid okay the second thing is um the
architectural
quality of the pyramid now there is a
misconception a myth the pyramids were
built by
slaves they had slaves they used slaves
but they never Ed slaves for religious
purposes right because slave you can't
really trust slaves so it was it was
tens of Labor tens of FS of laborers who
built the Pyramid together and it's a
complete mystery to
people how they're able to achieve such
a miraculous
building okay and so the answer is this
let's think for about for the past
Thousand Years the most impressive
buildings in the world are
usually
churches temples MOS right
so that just demonstrate the power of
religious devotion in the Act of
Creation so if if the Egyptians saw the
pyramids as the ultimate Temple as the
as bringing God on Earth you can imagine
every one of them would work very hard
in order to do their best does that make
sense okay
the third is the idea of the cult of the
skull so around this time and throughout
the
world people practice an ancest
worship so the way they did that usually
is um maybe they have a ancestor who was
what we guarded okay they would keep a
skull around they would decorate with
clay and Och her and they would use this
skull as maybe a portal into the outer
world to the spirit world in order to
draw inspiration to draw good luck from
this okay so the idea that they would
use the pharaoh's body as a portal into
the heavens is a very uh would be a very
common idea at that time all right and
then you
have cave paintings so remember uh way
back way early in the semester we looked
at Ice Ice Age cave paintings
Inside So these paintings inside caves
and we discussed these paintings were a
means of religious worship of bringing
the spirit world into our world
connecting the two okay in order to
celebrate life and
hunting okay then you have a place like
go
gole which is considered one of the
earliest
temples okay remember it is a religious
Monument on top of a hill okay which
would be also another way for you to
connect our world with the heavens and
for your worship draw Divine energy from
the
heavens so this in other words there's a
pattern of
humans trying to connect the spirit
world with our world through religious
worship and the pyramid
represents the AL UL imate
Temple does that make sense so so so the
pyramid is a
continuation of this sort of religious
devotion and worship and religious
practice okay all
right okay um any questions before I
move on
okay so um now the last question is why
did they stop in the
pyramid
and um there's a very good reason why
they stopped building a pyramid because
remember this pyramid was about creating
Eternal
peace pleasing the gods unifying the
world right that's a theory the problem
is this Theory doesn't work because in
about
2200 BC
CE so the
4.2
4.2 kiloyear event happened okay think
of this as a mini ice age where for
about 100 years there's a drought in
Egypt well that's a problem right
because the entire point of the pyramid
why people sacrificed themselves so hard
to work on the pyramid was to prevent a
drought in Egypt right it was to control
the Nile and they failed so this creates
first of all a crisis of Faith okay a
crisis of
Faith many now are forced to reject
their faith in the Pharaoh and now you
see the rise of the priesthood okay and
other gods as well so the first major
reason why they stop building the
pyramids is a question of
Faith second problem is in order to
build the pyramids you need a pyramid
economy okay a pyramid
economy and what the pent economy
represents is centralized planning right
centralization the pharoh and his Palace
are able to coordinate all the
resources of the state in order to
create the pyramids we know that when
when you have centralization you have
three problems the first is inequality
so if you're part of this plan economy
you do very well for yourself okay but
if you're not then you become poorer
okay so inequality is a huge issue but
you also a problem of corruption where
people in the
system
um they want to steal because it's just
easier to do okay and the third problem
is just waste it's not very efficient so
basically a pyramid the pyramid economy
is just a complete waste of
resources all right the third problem is
this okay and this this is actually a
much
more okay this is a huge problem okay
this idea of a NE
nihilistic religious
belief what this religious religious
saying is life doesn't matter it's death
that matters it's death that allows us
to be like Gods to be
Eternal right in order to ensure our
Ascent into godhood one we have to be
close to the Pharaoh okay we have to be
loyal to the Pharaoh but two we have to
ensure we obtain a lot of wealth in our
life okay so basically what Egypt was
doing during the pyramid economy was
taking all its grain all its resources
and then selling it overseas in order to
bring back precious metals that they
could put in their graves so that they
could take with take these pressure bals
go jewy into Afterlife with
them okay so basically they were just
taking all this tremendous wealth of
Egypt almost unlimited wealth of Egypt
and just squandering it gambling it away
basically and the promise of an eternal
afterlife and they didn't care about the
here and now they didn't care about
building a great nation they really
wen't concerned about ensuring everyone
was well off and prosperous and happy in
a
nation okay so you you had an elite who
was concerned about abusing of power in
order to steal as much money as possible
in order to ensure a good
afterlife okay and this is the three
major major reasons
why they stopped building the pyramids
okay one because it's a question of
Faith doesn't really work second is uh
the centralization creates inequality
corruption and waste and third is the
religious belief can only lead to um the
corruption of the state and tyranny okay
so I answer those three questions any
any any questions before I continue
okay
right so yeah that's a great Point okay
so you're absolutely right that even
though they sto building pyramids this
civilization would go on for another
2,000 years and it was still for the
majority of that a very prosperous
stable nation that was basically the
hegemon of the Western World okay um uh
so this is the Old Kingdom that that
that that's that's what they the Old
Kingdom focused on building the pyramids
but the Middle Kingdom and New Kingdom
would also have a lot of Glory as as
well so I I don't mean to negr uh their
society okay I I'm I'm just pointing out
some logical flaws in their society that
will lead to their uh eventure will
Decay because um even though uh the Old
Kingdom will collapse the society is
very resilient so as I said the Old
Kingdom will will be replaced by the
Middle Kingdom after large Civil War
also they will make changes to society
that will make Society much more stable
and the major change is to take all the
centralized powers of the Pharaoh and
then devolve it into the priesthood and
creating a priest to bureaucracy okay uh
which is very much like the confusion
bureaucracy in
China um and they will also start
importing new ideas from uh overseas so
so I I apologize if I'm implying this
that this is the end of Egypt it's not
we after the oak Kingdom after stop the
pyramids you will have a new flourishing
of creativity and innovation in in Egypt
that but but they stopped perceiving the
pyramids as the n on be all whereas and
the point the point I to make is during
the Old Kingdom they did perceive the
the pyramid as the manhan project okay
they really thought if we build this
thing then there will be Eternal peace
and you can also make the argument the
the um Israelites in the uh Bible make
fun of make fun of them because there's
a power the Tower of Babel story right
the to the Tower of Babel story where um
the humans are arrogantly trying to
build
a uh Tower up to heaven to be with God
right and you can argue that that's what
the pyramid
is and God laughs at them and mocks them
and they never succeed and then God
punishes them by making them speak
different languages
okay
right sure
okay so so this is a great question okay
what do the Egyptians remember about the
Great Pyramid so har is was running
about 400 BC okay and this about 2,000
years after the Great Pyramid and harus
travels around Egypt and and he's a
basically historian he's a journalist he
wants to know how they built the Great
Pyramid and what he discovers is the
Egyptians don't know not only do they
not know but they don't even know how to
rebuild one okay if you ask the Egyptian
in 400 BC can you build a pyramid
they've lost an
expertise okay and so um so so so so let
me elaborate on this when when I talk
about the pyramid economy me I'm talking
about three things I'm talking about
specialization
right just massive specialization
including how to carve Granite how to
move
Granite how to do measurements okay you
have specialization going on then you
have something called in in
institutionalization which is basically
creating a memory of this knowledge and
you do that through by passing this on
through your to your sons and your
grandsons and to maybe in maybe in a
guild or Workshop okay and then you also
have
systemization which is to say you have
to bring all these pieces
together okay so the pyramid economy was
extremely complex because you need all
three things to happen at the same time
specialization industrialization and
systematization you can also argue the
man who created the system the parent
economy his name is
imot okay and he's revered in Egypt as a
Divine figure okay he I mean he was a
basically Grand visor to the Pharaoh um
he was royalty but he was a man but he
was able to contribute so much to Egypt
that they defied him basically okay and
you can argue like his major
contribution was in creating this
pyramid economy that are all three
elements specialization intialization
and systemization okay because it's
actually very hard hard to put the
pieces together you need writing a
writing system you need um a financial
system you need a lot a lot of elements
okay I'm making this sound a lot easier
than uh it really is okay so that's the
first thing very complex second thing is
remember for the Egyptians and for the
Pharaoh the pyramids represented God on
earth right so there has to be mystery
and secrecy around the building of the
pyramid right so as I said what makes
the most sense is for them to build
these models around the pyramid so that
these working teams would know where to
go at what time okay but after they
build the pyramids it make sense for
them to destroy all records in order to
maintain a sense of divinity and
inspiration right they're trying to
create awe and fear and
inspiration so they would not want for
people to like know how to build a
pyramids they would think this has to be
a gift from God from the
Pharaoh okay does that make sense okay
but but that that's a great question
thanks okay any more questions before I
I move
on okay that's a great question where
was The Mummy of a
okay so in this Theory you have to
understand what matters is not the
pyramid what matters is the body the
Pharaoh right because it's a Pharaoh's
body that's sickled in the vine so if
that's s in the vine then you need a
priesthood a cult of the Pharaoh to
secure and take care of the body okay
does that make sense so in other words
um the there there had to be a team
taking care of the pharaoh's body The
Mummy
and that to ensure first and foremost
its safety okay so the Great Pyramid was
part of a complex called the Giza
complex so there actually two other
pyramids and then around the pyramids
are these tombs of people who worked for
the Pharaoh but who were not Divine okay
and you can make the argument what
they're trying to do is create a
constellation right because when you
look at the Sky Stars don't travel by
themselves they travel in constellations
so makes sense for the Son and the
grandson to be buried alongside curfew
but as lesser dieties as lesser pyramids
to to show the Egyptian people the
harmony balance and Order of the of of
the
system
okay and what's great about the system
is it ensures loyalty of people working
for the Pharaoh because if you're loyal
you're granted a tomb around the Pharaoh
which guarantees your Ascension into the
Eternal afterlife so you could be
eternally with the Pharaoh okay so this
is a system of morality
basically
right so this is fine because there's
lots of protections for the Pharaoh
right he surrounded by many different uh
systems but when um the system was
breaking down it was clear that Egypt
was um breaking to Civil War then the
cult of the Pharaoh had a responsibility
to take the body and place it somewhere
that no one could find it right because
again what matters in this system is
that the pyramid what matters is the
body the body is what gives the pyramids
energy and power so they have to protect
that part that body at all cost so the
reason why we can't find the body is
they made sure we couldnot find the body
right because the body is the mechanism
the portal by which the Pharaoh will
resurrect himself if we have that then
we control the Pharaoh we control
God okay does that make sense so they
must have a secret caves or places where
they put these bodies and the purpose is
to ensure they can never be
found okay so great question thank you
any more questions before I finish the
class can you talk a little bit about
how that support
okay um so um what's inside the pyramid
so first of all um the parents have been
around for about 45 New
Years um
and uh to tomb rating was a huge problem
right so what it was actually in the
pyramids um we are not we we can't be
sure about right because of time because
of Tomb rating okay
um we we didn't find that much inside
the
pyramid okay there were no pictures
artwork there were very few
hieroglyphics inside the Great Pyramid
there are hieroglyphics and paintings
and other pyramids okay but inside the
great pyr we haven't found that much
which I think gives even more Credence
to my theory that this was meant to be a
temple of
worship
okay and this is also why people believe
it's a tomb because there's so few
artwork if you if it was if it were a
temple instead you would imagine it
there would be a lot of
artwork
okay okay any more questions before I uh
finish the
class are you guys clear so far all
right so I want to finish the class with
a different question which
is why is it like my interpretation is
so radically different from the
mainstream academic interpretation
okay and I want to propose the way that
our minds work today are rly different
from the way that the minds of people
like the Egyptians worked okay for three
reasons today the Egyptian people had
a
preliterate mind they also had a
pre uh science mind also pre
capitalistic okay so let me
explain preliterate is very simple it
just means they didn't read and write
they just
spoke and we are taught the literate
mind is more powerful than the oral mind
but that's not true okay if you think
about it the oral mind works through
imagination the your mind um is capable
of tremendous memory because back then
in order to do anything you have to
memorize a lot of information now we can
just um go online right so their minds
even though were preliterate they were
much more
imaginative than we are today and their
memories were stronger that's why they
were able to build a great pyramids
because everyone was able to memorize
the model and figure out his or her
place inside the
structure they were also able to
imagine in their heads the Great Pyramid
remember Homer and Virgil the way that
children learn Homer and Virgil is by
memorizing them okay and you can do that
there are people today who memorize the
Quran and who memorize the
Torah okay it takes some time but you're
able to do that so back then they were
able to build the parent because they
were able to visualize the pyramid in
their
minds and you can do that with a
pre-literate mind
okay second is the idea of pre- science
so in today's world we science is our
God okay so in in school you're taught
the scientific method which is basically
um you collect information then you
synphase it then you write your thesis
okay it's a step-by-step logical process
but if you're if you're a pre-scientific
mind then where do you get your ideas
from you you you get your ideas through
divine inspiration through God right so
you can make the argument like back then
they were capable of these Grand
ideas that we're not cap capable of
today because we're locked in by the
discipline of
science the other problem with science
is it's very materialistic meaning we're
focused on the here and now we're focus
on what we can see as as opposed to what
we feel or what we
believe right so when we look at the
pyramid we're always about what was
built instead of like what were they
feeling when they were building this and
that's a huge
difference the third difference is pre-
capitalistic today we do things to make
money we come to school because we want
to get a job because we we want to make
money to buy things okay it's a very
utilitarian
mindset but for most of human history
most civilizations were not capitalistic
they were religious they were focused on
community they were focused on what they
could contribute to the betterment of
the people around them they were
concerned about their relationship with
God they were concerned about how to
create peace in the world they're asking
big questions like what is good and what
is evil what is justice what is fairness
what is
Justice and
so they were much more focused on
building a pyramid as a way to build
community and peace and Eternity on
Earth okay so in other words what's
interesting is even though we are much
more technologically Advance we're much
wealthier than the Egyptians we don't
have the imagination we don't have the
will to build something like the Great
Pyramid
again and that's why I think even today
the Great Pyramid captures the
imagination of so many people around the
world because it's really beyond our own
imagination it really shows the
limitations of our own
imagination right okay that's it any any
questions
okay yeah let's all be let's all be
intuitive and pre science here yeah
yeah okay um so this um begins a bron
age okay this is this is part of the
Bron age Egypt is the greatest
civilization of the Bron age um next
class we'll we'll look at Mesopotamia
and the indis valley civilization okay
so there are three great bronate
civilizations Egypt uh Mesopotamia and
in valy okay